THE PRELIMINARY INQUIRY HAS
IDENTIFIED AND CAN ONLY BE
ANSWERED BY A DEEPER REVIEW.
>> THOSE CLAIMS ARE
PREPOSTEROUS.
THEY PRESENT AN OUT AND OUT
POLITICAL FARCE.
FIRST OF ALL ASKING CHINA TO
MAKE REPARATIONS FOR THESE KIND
OF CLAIMS, THEY HAVE NO LEGAL
BASIS.
>> Bill: THIS WAS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT INTERVIEW FROM NBC,
CRITICS WERE CRITICIZING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
HAS ALSO SAID BEIJING WILL PAY
THE PRICE.
I WANT TO BRING IN FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT’S BOOKS SPOKESP
ORTEGA.
HE SAID IN THE INTERVAL OF 50
DAYS, WHAT WAS THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT DOING?
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE DATE
THEY SHUT DOWN WUHAN TO THE DATE
THE UNITED STATES HAD A NUMBER
OF CASES, AWARE OF THOSE 50 DAYS
GONE?
YOUR REACTION TO THE COMMENT
FROM BEIJING FIRST.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WERE DOING RECENTLY, WAS
EVACUATING AMERICAN CITIZENS.
SO, WHILE AMERICANS WERE
ENJOYING THE SUPER BOWL AND
WATCHING THAT GAME, OUR FOREIGN
SERVICE OFFICERS AND WUHAN WERE
WORKING ON GETTING THE PLANES OF
AMERICANS OUT OF CHINA AND OFF
OF CRUISE SHIPS.
WE CONTINUED THAT EFFORT AND WE
NOW HAVE 70,000 AMERICANS THAT
WE HAVE REPATRIATED.
SECRETARY POMPEO SAID SOMETHING
THIS MORNING THAT I THINK IS
REALLY KEY, THAT COMMUNIST PARTY
OFFICIALS ARE SAYING.
DISINFORMATION CREATES A RISK.
SO WHILE THERE IS NOISE IN THE
SPACE, BUT WE STILL DON’T HAVE
CREDIBLE SCIENTISTS, CREDIBLE
INVESTIGATORS AND CREDIBLE
SCIENTISTS THAT CAN GO INTO
THESE LABS SO CHINA WANTS TO BE
THE PARTNER, IF THEY WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT.
AND BY OPENING UP THE COUNTRY
NOT JUST TO THE UNITED STATES
BUT TO THE WORLD, CREDIBLE
DOCTORS FROM AROUND THE WORLD.
>> Bill: HAVE YOU MADE THAT
REQUEST TO BEIJING?
>> WE SAY IT ALMOST EVERY DAY
PRETTY LOUDLY AND THAT’S ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS REVIEWED THE 60-90 DAY
REVIEW ON THE W.H.O.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT
REVIEW PROCESS RIGHT NOW AND THE
MOST FUNDAMENTAL IMPORTANT
THING, BILL, THAT WE HAVE TO
SOLVE, THAT THE WORLD HAS TO
SOLVE, IS HOW DO WE STOP THE
PANDEMIC OF THE SCALE FROM EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN.
THE WORLD CANNOT ANSWER THE
QUESTION, THAT BECOMES
TRANSPARENT AND GIVES DATA THAT
SCIENTISTS AND DOCTORS CAN
VERIFY.
WE ARE STILL WAITING ON THAT.
>> Bill: USED TO SAY THAT
EVERY DAY, IS THE ANSWER NO OR
IS IT A MUTED RESPONSE?
DID YOU GET AN ANSWER?
>> NO.
WE GET A LOT OF DISINFORMATION
THAT YOU SEE FROM COMMUNIST
PARTY OFFICIALS AND TO THE BEST
OF OUR KNOWLEDGE WE STILL DON’T
HAVE -- THE WORLD DOES NOT HAVE
THOSE LIVE VIRUS SAMPLES.
>> Bill: IN THE MEANTIME YOU
HAVE THE FOREIGN MINISTRY SAYING
POMPEO IS ACCUSING CHINA OF A
COVER-UP.
I STOPPED PLAYING THE POLITICAL
GAME, BETTER SAVE ENERGY ON
SAVING LIVES.
WHAT IS THE NATURE OF THE
RELATIONSHIP.
WHAT IS THE STRAIN ON THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BEIJING AND
WASHINGTON TODAY.
AND SOMETIMES THAT’S ON
UNCOMFORTABLE TO HEAR.
WE ARE WILLING TO WORK IN THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT ON THE SPIRIT
OF TRANSPARENCY.
AND THAT’S WHY WE KEEP PUBLICLY
PRESSURING AND CALLING FOR
OPENNESS AND TRANSPARENCY FOR
THIS DATA.
LESSON, AND DIPLOMACY THERE ARE
AREAS OF THE WORLD IN WHICH THE
UNITED STATES AND CHINA, AND OUR
INTERESTS CONVERGE AND THERE ARE
AREAS THAT THEY DON’T.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CALLED
FOR SINCE THE BEGINNING OF HIS
PRESIDENCY IS RECIPROCITY IN HIS
RELATIONSHIP.
HE HAS CALLED FOR A FAIR AND
FREE TRADE AND HE’S NOT ASKING
FOR ANYTHING OF CHINA THAT HE’S
NOT ASKING FOR THE REST OF THE
WORLD AND THAT IS AN EQUAL
RELATIONSHIP, WHETHER IT’S
TRADER, IP THEFT OR THE
BEGINNING OF --
>> Bill: I GOT TO GET TO
ANOTHER TOPIC HERE.
GREASING THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
HAS NOT YET SURE A SAMPLE OF THE
LIBRARY REST, IS THAT CORRECT?
>> TO THE BEST OF OUR KNOWLEDGE.
>> Bill: BECAUSE THE DNA WAS
SHARED WITH DOCTORS IN ENGLAND
BACK IN JANUARY, IS THAT TRUE?
>> I DID NOT MAJOR IN BIOLOGY SO
I WILL LET THE SCIENTISTS SPEAK
TO THAT BUT TO THE BEST OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, THOSE EARLY
LIVE VIRUS SAMPLES HAVE NOT BEEN
SHARED.
>> Bill: OKAY, THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION, THE LEADER
SAID EARLIER TODAY THAT FROM THE
BEGINNING THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION ACTED QUICKLY AND
DECISIVELY TO WARN THE WORLD.
WE SOUNDED THE ALARM EARLY AND
SOUNDED IT OFTEN.
IS THAT TRUE OR NOT TODAY?
>> IF THIS WAS TRUE WE WOULD NOT
BE GOING THROUGH THE REVIEW
PROCESS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HASN’T PLUMMETED.
>> IS A WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION LYING?
>> I THINK THAT’S A LITTLE
STRONG.
WE ARE CONDUCTING THIS REVIEW
PROCESS BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE
GOOD STEWARDS OF THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER MONEY.
WE KNOW THERE HAS BEEN TO A
NUMBER OF MISSTEPS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PROCESS AND SO
WE ARE ON A REVIEW.
TO SEE W.H.O. REFORM, CAN THEY
BECOME MORE TRANSPARENT IN A WAY
THAT WILL HELP SOLVE THE
PANDEMIC.
WE HAVE GIVEN THEM $140 BILLION
IN JUST THE PAST TWO DECADES,
THE GLOBAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT EXISTS NOW
IS THANKS TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
PEOPLE.
YOU JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE REAL RESULTS IN TAXPAYER
MONEY.
>> Bill: A FEW SECONDS LEFT.
IT IS A LEADER OF NORTH KOREA
ALIVE OR DEAD?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP I THINK SPOKE
TO THAT ON MONDAY SO I WILL LET
HIS WORDS STAND.
SECRETARY POMPEO HAS SAID THAT
OUR MISSION NO MATTER WHO IS IN
CHARGE REMAINS THE SAME
NORTH KOREA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS CHARGED US
WITH MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
DENUCLEARIZE HOLY AND FAIRLY
METHOD IN NORTH KOREA AND THAT